john is with us to start this hour off
in kansas city hi
john how are you not too bad i
appreciate you taking my call
sure what's up hey uh for about the last
uh i'd say dozen years i've been
focusing on
real estate investing as a as a landlord
and i do a few flips here and there but
um i've um i focused on that and i
i don't feel good about some of my cash
investments as far as like ira goes
i feel you know real good about what
i've done with with real estate and what
that's done for my net worth
but uh you know at this time should i
just continue on with my real estate
investing
or do i need to put more money in my ira
i i have about 150
and i'm 50 years old about 150 my ira
well the point of getting retirement is
to have some wealth
right i don't really care what it's in
as long as you're comfortable with it
i'm only comfortable investing in two
things i invest in good growth stock
mutual funds
and i have a lot in that in my
retirement accounts
now if you're in a bank ira you said
cash and you're making one percent
then you need to roll that and get with
the smartvestor pro and get it in a
mutual fund
well what i meant was long-term you know
long-term cash
it's it's with a uh investment company
how's it making any money
yes yes it's doing well okay so what's
the gripe
well i just don't feel good about it i
guess as one saying
why should i be a little should i be a
little more well-rounded
you don't well you're heavy real estate
right
you're you don't feel good about that or
you don't feel good about the
ira investors good about being heavily
invested in real estate i mean i feel
good for what it's done for me
it's it's it's performed well i get a
really good you know
uh return on my investment on a
percentage basis
i'm just looking forward to another 10
or 15 years when i want to retire
yeah is are the properties all paid off
they are
okay and what's your total uh value in
your real estate portfolio
about 1.2 million way to go man
very well done well i uh i am personally
just you know this is who you're asking
uh
way heavier in real estate uh for two
reasons
one is i bought a bunch of real estate
at a nickel to a dime on the dollar in
08.
and so that stuff has gone through the
freaking roof since i bought it at the
bottom
comparatively i mean the the lost values
in oa
recovered within 18 or 24 months and
then on top of that it has appreciated
dramatically since then
um and i'm an old real estate dog i got
my real estate license in 1978 man
so i i love that business and i love
that investment i'm very comfortable
with it so
um you know the uh way
more than 50 in real estate in my net
worth
and so but i'm very comfortable with
that i'm not worried about it because
the real estate's all doing well it's
not
got if i got a piece of real estate then
do well i get rid of it but i don't get
into that very often
um so there's no rule that says
that you can't be there and other people
on the other hand hate being a landlord
and they've got all their money in
mutual funds which is just fine
those are the two things i put money in
i don't really put money in anything
else
yeah kind of same here yeah um i do have
a home mortgage i don't feel great about
it but
you know let's get that cleared off
that'll probably help you yeah
right you know if you pop one of those
investment properties and pay that thing
off that wouldn't make me mad
but i mean have you done something
theoretically wrong
by the way that i teach or run my life
or chris teaches or runs his life no you
haven't
okay well my my thing about the you know
like my home mortgage is about 300k
and my house is probably worth double
that um
so i'm about 50 there i always look at
the interest rate on my home mortgage
and think well i'm making a lot more
with you know with my money
in the real estate that's full that's
complete bull
if your house if your house was paid off
you wouldn't go borrow on it to buy a
rental house when you're sitting on a
million and a half and
a million two and paid for real estate
if you thought debt was great you would
have been deep in debt on that stuff
you don't think well uh so if
you know if if i if some of my real
estate brings me you know
uh 15 to 25 percent return
i would not borrow on my house to buy
that
okay well i i the only thing i've
borrowed you know
my mortgage is just on my house i know
effectively you've borrowed on your
house to buy that because you're not
willing to sell it to pay off your house
it's the same math right so you can do
whatever you want to do
i pay off that and stay out of debt and
i got out of debt a long time ago i
don't borrow money
and so when a pandemic comes or a 2008
comes
right or a 911 comes i'm the little pig
in the brick house the wolf can huff and
puff and i'm ready
and john you've done a great job of
course paying off the rental properties
and that's great
now as dave was talking you need pivot
let's look at your primary residence
this is your home for goodness sake
you want that thing paid off and out of
your life so that that needs to be
the next mission well if you're making
15 on a piece of real estate dude you're
not making that in a mutual fund
it's got a higher hassle factor than the
mutual fund has but
um you're not making that on your mutual
fund so i make more on my real estate
than i do on my mutual funds
but the mutual funds are less hassle and
um
you know so it's whichever one you wanna
do
it doesn't really matter the main thing
is grow money